we've been talking about sort of how
these lies get laundered through the
system obviously the State of the Union
was on Tuesday night and I was
fascinated while watching this because
you know one of the the memes these days
is that we're all watching the same
movie and having wildly different
reactions to things and I saw people
that I respect that that saw something
very different than I saw so I want to
show you one clip of Biden and the way
that our politicians and then the media
launder the lies disrupted our supply
chains and Putin's unfair and brutal war
in Ukraine disrupted energy supplies as
well as Food Supplies blocking all that
grain in Ukraine but we're a better
position than any country on Earth right
now but we have more to do but here at
home inflation is coming down here at
home gas prices are down a dollar fifty
from their Peak food inflation is coming
down not fast enough but coming down
inflation is falling every month for the
last six months or take-home pay has
gone up
additionally over the last two years a
record 10 million Americans apply to
start new businesses 10 million
and by the way
every time
okay so I think everyone watching gets
how virtually everything he said there
was a lie or a confusion yes inflation
has come down a tiny bit after
skyrocketing yes gas prices have come
down a tiny bit after skyrocketing uh in
the wage that he's talking about is not
going up as fast as inflation so you're
still losing money and they did put a
whole bunch of people out of work
because of covid the policy that he
still has going uh till May uh Marissa
were you pulling your hair out during
this thing or what I I was actually
learning quite a bit from him because
what you know I run a non-profit so what
maybe what I'll do is fire my entire
staff 150 people and then in three
months I'll go back to the board and say
look at me I'm so amazing I just hired
150 people
with great productivity so you know
there's quite a bit to learn from our
president not in a good way uh was I
pulling my hair out I mean every I I can
dissect every sentence there and pull my
hair out I mean the energy part is just
abysmal as well the first thing he did
in office was cut the Keystone Pipeline
and make America you know essentially
poorer
right and Viva he also seemingly all he
has to do for people to basically say
it's good is not fall off the stage
right I mean basically his as long as
his eye doesn't explode which happened
during one of the debates pretty much
everybody's like my God he's still got
it he he I I feel bad making this
observation but he reminds me his facial
expressions remind me of my grandmother
when she was like 102 years old it's not
normal yeah
um and it's like it's people who have
seen it know what it looks like but the
lies it's everybody needs to read or
Listen to George Orwell's 1984 when you
have the government talking about how
prices have gone down rations have gone
up first of all having gone down from
rocket high prices because of
incompetence is not a success it's a
mitigation of failure uh and then at the
end of the day you don't even know if
any of it's true but the energy and
Marissa touched on it on the one end
cutting the Keystone Pipeline which
pissed Canada off as well but also
talking about how Russia's interfering
with energy while allegedly according to
um oh geez I forgot his name now someone
will help me the the journalist who just
broke this covered the story while
they're allegedly sabotaging the north
stream pipelines to Germany everything
they accused their enemies of doing is
what they themselves have done it's pure
confession through projection if you'd
like more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell